من السهل جدًا أن أفهم أنني أتيت
من بلد يسمى الجزائر
و
لقد ولدت في عائلة من الموسيقيين
والدي والدي من زوجتي كنت أ
سيد كبير رامونالوس الموسيقى
العزيز
وكبرت
في الموسيقى الشرقية
في سن ال 15 لعبت فيها
الأوركسترا بجانب والدي من بلدي
زوج الأم
وهذا هو السبب
لدي علاقة خاصة مع
الموسيقى الشرقية في جيناتي
ما في جذوري الموسيقية
أحواض السمك
تماما لأن
كما أخبرتك أنني ولدت فيها
هذه الموسيقى والموسيقى العربية لها
يمر عبر عروقي
إنها كل جذوري وعندما
أتى
لفرض في فرنسا
كنت يتيم من بلدي
الجزائر التي تيتمتها هذه الموسيقى أنا
إنشاء دليل جديد
من الواضح في دليلي هناك
دائما كان لها التأثير الشرقي
إنها الحقيقة ولكن من ناحية أخرى
أعطاني ميزة لأنني كنت كذلك
إنه مختلف تمامًا عن الآخرين
مطربك الذي فرضت فيه لوريان
الغرب والغرب في الشرق
لذلك كنت مخلصًا لي
جذوري الموسيقية وفية لي
تحديد
وأنا لم أغش في التعبير عن نفسي
في موسيقاي
أعرف تقريبًا من هو جمهوري
أعرف
أنا أقوم بتكييف لقطتي فيما يتعلق بـ
للناس الذين يأتون لرؤيتي
على سبيل المثال بالنسبة للبنانيين سأفعل
غناء بيروت
سأغني بالعربية وسأغني
بالفرنسية بالإسبانية
إنها كل جذوري الموسيقية
سأفعل ثم أغاني
يجب ألا تنسى بداياتي وداعا
البلد وداعا بلدي
وأطفال من جميع البلدان التي غنيت بها
أعرف ماذا أفعل لإرضاء
الجمهور والبدء
تركت بيتي
حياتي وحياتي الحزينة
هذا القطار يعمل بدون سبب
تركت شمسي
تركت والدتي
[موسيقى]
تستيقظ الذاكرة
لي بعد حليفي
[موسيقى]
فتيات بلدي ينادونني
وهرانو الشرقية
[موسيقى]
لا تزال أسس بلدي
مهنة وبالتالي أنا
محكوم عليها بالغناء
دائما اذهب والغناء
لكن لدي أيضًا أغاني جديدة
فقط يستغرق الأمر وقتًا للاندماج
القديمة أي أن القديمة
لا تزال آثارا تركتها
ضد ذلك الذي تعرفه هذا العام أفعل
60 عامًا من حياتي المهنية وستستمر
متجرك هو كل شيء
سأغني دبي وسأغني
قليلا في جميع أنحاء العالم هذه هي البداية
من جولة حول العالم
إنه لأمر رائع أنه امتياز
غير عادى
على وجه التحديد
أدركت خلال بلدي
مهنة في مسارح بلدي
في البداية لم يكن هناك شباب
الأجيال الجديدة مع القديم
التي كانت مماثلة لي
التوليد
و
لأنني لم أكن مغنيًا في حياتي من قبل
الموضة من أي وقت مضى
وشيئا فشيئا الأخبار
الأجيال المضافة إلى
العمر وعندما تذهب لرؤية بلدي
يظهر أنك ستشاهد الكثير منها
الشباب الآن الذي يسعدني لأنه
هذا يجعلني سعيدا لأن هؤلاء
الناس لن ينجبوا ومتى
سأذهب وسأغادر
تتبع وسيتذكر الناس كل شيء
وقت لي كثيرا
[موسيقى]
أنا الآن أبلغ من العمر 84 عامًا
سأسرع ليجعلني أتيت لدي
يحسده قبل أن يترك اسمه على الأقل
مرة واحدة إلى مسقط رأسي بلدي
البلد يجر بلا سبب كل الأصدقاء
أن لدي شعبي هناك
جزائري اخواني
ربما سيأتي أنا لا أقول
لا في المستقبل أنا لا أقول الشوكولاته
[موسيقى]